foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello hello
welcome everybody Welcome to Club Fugazi
my name is
and for that reason I go by Mikko you
don't have to attempt that I am the
director of development at longnow
foundation and I have an ask for you
please silence your devices you can do
it surreptitiously while I continue
talking there is table
so
continue enjoying yourself after the
program and stick around for a good
conversation if you so desire
now many of you here in fact I think
most of you here are long now members
including people on the live stream
hello
thank you thank you thank you
your support makes our work possible in
addition to our esteemed seminar
sponsors
you can support our work even further by
telling your friends about long now
because you will know people as
interesting as yourselves and we would
love to grow the community with your
help
please consider that
now I have the pleasure of introducing
tonight's speaker
Henry Farrell is a professor working on
democracy and international Affairs at
Johns Hopkins University he was a fellow
at the center for advanced study in the
behavioral sciences who are our partners
for this talk indeed that is a good
shout right there
and Henry's most recent book is called
underground Empire how America
weaponized the world economy after his
talk uh Henry will be joined on stage
for a conversation by Nils Gilman who is
senior vice president of programs at The
berggrun Institute and Deputy editor of
noema magazine and after the talk and
the Q a there will be copies of Henry's
new book signed copies available close
to the entrance right there but for now
please join me in welcoming Henry
Farrell
so thank you so much all for coming here
and I have to say how wonderful it is
for me to be here this evening I've been
following the long now conversation for
years and it is just a genuine thrill to
be a part of that conversation in a
small way for just one evening this is
something that is very very exciting and
it makes me very very very happy indeed
so what I'm going to be talking about
tonight what I'm going to be bringing to
this conversation is this discussion of
I put it in the official title for this
talk the complex complex aftermath of
globalization and the idea behind that
title is very straightforward you want
to give a title which gives a sense of
the topic but maybe it doesn't say quite
too much about the topic so that people
don't think that they have a too good
idea an idea of what it is that you're
going to say so that they're perhaps a
little intrigued so that they'll perhaps
come along and see and find out what it
is that you have to talk about and I've
got a confession to make which is that
this is the official title of the talk
no actually the working title that I had
when I was actually thinking about the
talk and trying to put together its
themes and its arguments I had a very
different title a title that is probably
going to be completely incomprehensible
to most people until after the talk is
finished which is that this is the talk
about the bagel and the poly crisis now
I can see already yes when I I worry
that there might be a little bit of a
rush to the doors yourself what in the
name of God God could possibly
be a talk here so how could we have a
talk which brings together these two
very different things most people in
this room I suspect probably aren't
particularly familiar with the concept
of the poly crisis but it sounds very
vague and abstract and academic and all
of these things and so what in the name
of God could it possibly have to do with
an ordinary Bagel so what I'll say is
that by the end of the talk you will
have a good idea of the logic of how the
bagel and the poly crisis actually fit
together in ways that make sense and
that are not just reducible to the piece
of cheesy AI generated art that I'm
using to uh illustrate the ways that the
two actually observed Collide in some
way shape or form
that is not the only confession that I'm
going to make this evening the second
confession and I suspect that this is a
pretty common confession that is made or
that should be made by people who are
giving long Now talks is that I have a
book to promote this is a book which is
co-authored with Abraham Newman it is
called answer as you just heard
underground Empire how America
weaponized the world economy and it is a
wonderful book it is a great book it is
fun the financial times described it
this week as being a gripping book and
it gives you a important story about the
world it tells us how the world economy
how the world's Communications networks
how the world's manufacturing networks
all of these were supposed to be
decentralized in globalization and it
turns out that they get centralized once
they become centralized this allows the
United States to figure out ways to use
them it as tools of coercion as Tools in
order to surveil the world and now over
the last few years where begins to see
what happens as other great cars as
businesses is as an Ordinary People
begin to figure out what is happening a
new complex difficult and weird politics
are resulting so that is the book uh
there are copies as has already been
mentioned at the back of the room and if
you're watching this online then I just
urge you to go to your local Bookshop
r21 through go to your book uh
purchasing online services
and together immediately and you will
have a ton of up but here's the third
confession here's my third confession
this is the last thing you're going to
hear specifically about the book during
this talk this is not going to be your
standard Talk of the book this is going
to be your talk about all of this stuff
that I would have loved to have put into
the book but I would have loved to have
stuffed into the books to 188 pages but
that didn't particularly fit very well
because it is not the niche argument the
neat Logic the uh the kinds of things
that you can put into a taught tense
narrative it is in a certain sense it is
the book's weird cause it is a weird
cousin that comes out of nowhere that
grabs you by your cardigan tells you
urgently about all sorts of stuff that
it is insistence that you need to know
about that you didn't know about before
and that that for some important reason
that it's partly incomprehensible you
need to know about right now so this is
what I'm going to do I'm going to give
you a talk about all of the things that
I think that are important that are
around the book but didn't necessarily
fit into a simple clear story that would
answer would would translate well into
the uh into the kind of format that you
need in order to be able to tell a book
length story so what is the story that
I'm going to talk about this evening
it's a very different set of questions
but it is a set of questions that really
touch upon this broader broader problem
of where we are after globalization
and the idea behind it is
as I say I'm a I'm a professor I teach
international relations in my day job
and really what it is it's a talk about
America's relationship with the world
and how America understands this
relationship with the world
what kinds of simplifications do policy
makers make in order to try and
comprehend this vast and
incomprehensible set of problems that
they are faced with I'm going to discuss
how we have talked about this during
history I'm going to look at the last 70
or 80 years of a history of the United
States relationship with the world the
simplification of the policy makers used
during the period of War and the period
of globalization and I am also going to
pray to God that Nils Gilman is the only
professional professional historian in
this audience because I'm going to
commit serious crimes against history
I'm going to give you uh 80 years of
extremely complex developments in
approximately 10 minutes and hope that
you don't spot the gaping flaws in the
narrative that I am providing once I've
done I will talk about where we are now
now that these simplifications have been
Stripped Away what kinds of problems we
face and this is the moment where the
big reveal will happen about the
relationship between the bagel and the
poly crisis and then in the best
tradition of these talks after having
given you very very detailed loving
descriptions of the Grim problems that
we face I'm going to provide you with a
hopelessly inadequate set of answers
about what possibilities we have to
address them and what possibilities we
have to escape them so this is more or
not what you're going to hear over the
next 20-25 minutes or so
so let me start with the Cold War and
let me start as I say what I really want
to talk about is America's relationship
with the world and the ways in which
American policy makers the people who
made decisions think and thought about
America's relationship with the world
and how they thought what were the
problems that they wanted to solve on
the one hand and however the means that
they could use could to try to address
these problems with the other and if you
look at the Cold War the period of the
Cold War the answer to what the problems
were the policy makers perceived is very
straightforward most of the big problems
are ones that really dominated their
imagination had to do with National
Security
and National Security did not just mean
guns bombs troops dispositions nuclear
weapons all of the aspects of military
security that we tend to focus on during
the Cold War National Security was a
much more pervasive much more
all-encompassing set of issues because
the United States saw itself as being
pitched in battle against an adversary
the United the the USSR the Soviet Union
which it saw as being engaged in
Conflict against this on a number of
different offense not just the military
front of Economics uh the Soviet Union
obviously had a very different system of
how to run an economy politics it was an
authoritarian system as opposed to
America's uh deeply flawed democracy so
Society it had very different ways of
running its Society even culture became
a battlefield so we had all of these
different battlefields in which America
felt that its National Security was
potentially under threat this had a lot
of pathologies which went together with
it a lot of Cold War paranoia which uh
some of you would likely already be
familiar with but that was the broad set
of problems that America faced and when
American policy makers thought about the
quote big picture unquote and they
tended to think about these problems
they tended to lump them together under
the rubric of National Security
so how do they try to solve the problems
of National Security with the
technocratic state and again this is a
crude simplification which will have
historians if they're in the audience
rendering their hair in horror at the
damage that a political scientist is
doing to the complex and subtle stories
that they have to tell but nonetheless I
think it's a reasonable approximation
this was a period when the U.S
government especially when it came to
U.S relations with the broader world the
US government had quite extraordinary
degrees of power and the technocratic
state was a reference to the idea that
the state the federal government should
have the expertise and the power to
identify and to protect America's
interests across a very very very wide
array of different fields of endeavor
and this was especially true with
relation to the economy if you looked at
the way that the estate in this period
governed stations with other countries
there was a quite extraordinary degree
of State intervention into the economy
and into global trade so there was
limited but real trade with allies and
with the adversary for very long periods
there was next to no trade worth talking
about at all because the United States
worried the trade would only provide
resources to an adversary which wanted
to strangle it equally wide varieties of
different forms of knowledge exchange of
technological exchange all of these were
governed by the same a very very
extensive export control laws if you
were a U.S citizen and you engaged in
slightly two specific technical
conversation with somebody who was a
non-us national you could be prosecuted
under export control laws and so we saw
a very very great degree of of control
of the spread of scientific knowledge as
well I and so does that lots of
consequences some of which were
pernicious and some of which were
identified by people at the time
President Eisenhower when he laughed at
the presidency famously gave an address
where he warned of the dangers of what
he called the military industrial uh
complex and so what he was warning about
here was not just the kinds of things
that we think about when we think about
the military-industrial complex today
the kinds of relationships between
military contractors in the Pentagon
Eisenhower was worried about that but he
had a much much bigger set of fears that
he wanted to express which was that the
United States was a country where much
of the entrepreneurial energy much of
the scientific energy was effectively
being controlled by the federal
government was being directed by the
federal government's priorities by its
security needs and a lot of other things
were seen as being secondary unnecessary
are irrelevant and Eisenhower being a
moderate conservative a moderate
Republican worried about what this would
do to American Discovery American
entrepreneurialism over the longer term
and indeed if you look to see many of
the important discoveries that actually
began to come really into flower During
the period after this during the period
of globalization actually had their
origins in this military industrial
complex if for example you think about
the internet famously the internet is a
byproduct of Pentagon spending if you
look at Silicon Valley as Margaret
O'Mara has documented in a really great
book The Code which I recommend that you
read if you haven't read it already the
Silicon Valley and the commercialization
of the semiconductor were again
byproducts of military spending and the
need of the military for example for
sophisticated missile guidance systems
which led to the development of
semiconductors and similar Technologies
and then these are course discovered
civilian applications as well so this is
a period when the problem
primarily have to do with National
Security these are the problems that
occupy people's minds and these
solutions to that problem primarily have
to do with the exercise of the power of
the technocratic state so what happens
when the Cold War finishes when the
Berlin Berlin Wall comes down and all of
these wonderful things begin to happen
we get the Glorious dawn of
globalization and a very very different
way of thinking about the world now I
should say this is not something that
happens overnight this Builds on
tendencies that have already been
building up during the Carter
Administration during the earlier part
of the regular Administration we have
already began gone to see some of this
happening domestically
but it really begins to reshape the
United States understanding of its place
in the world as well when the Soviet
Union collapses relatively quickly
the United States finds a settlement
world where it does not have an
adversary anymore instead it sees an
endless progress of potential Triumph it
has won its system has won its system is
being embraced by everybody China may
still be communist and name but uh
people hope and people assume that as it
Embraces the free market it too will
gradually become more liberal and so you
see a move away from security fears
National Security it certainly doesn't
disappear the Pentagon is still going
strong but the imagination of policy
makers is primarily focused on a
different set of goals that have to do
with prosperity and trying to generate
it trying to maintain it this is seen as
a master key to a better world now that
the arrival of the Soviet Union has
disappeared and the more that the world
becomes prosperous along U.S lines the
better off not only will the world be
but the United States will be too and we
begin to see of course the many changes
that happen as the United States begins
to push this as a different political
agenda and as different International
institutions begin to open up and begin
to embrace this as well so if the if
those Prosperity be
fine this is not through the
technocratic state
very great extent uh recedes into the
wings and instead people start to push
for Solutions via free markets via the
market system and here if you look at
the ideas that are important in
justifying this you see the ideas of
Chicago economists playing an especially
important role Milton Friedman here's a
justification of uh markets as enabling
individual Choice far far better than
States is something that is a plays an
extremely important role he and his
colleagues push for the notion that
markets are efficient and that state
intervention into the marketplace except
under highly limited conditions is a bad
idea and going together with this Milton
Friedman is a irrepressible Optimist is
a more pessimistic vision of his uh of
his colleague at the University of
Chicago Friedrich Von Hayek who has this
very different notion of the market
system not necessarily as produced
efficiencies but as being this wonderful
system of knowledge that markets take
all of these incredibly complex
relations of supply and demand and they
allowed us to work in a decentralized
way through the miraculous intervention
of the price mechanism and also at the
same time they enable new forms of
Discovery because the market is this
spontaneous order it is far more
conducive to open-ended discovery of
what people might actually want than any
system that is run by a government ever
ever possibly could be so this logic is
really the logic that we see prevailing
in how it is that policy makers think
about the US's role in the world up
until six or seven years ago and it also
seems According to some people to have
the answers or some answers at least to
National Security questions as well
there's another Friedman who's important
Thomas Friedman who is still writing for
the New York Times who in his arguments
about a flat world suggests that a world
which is based upon more and more
globalization more Market Freedom more
Market competition is going to be a
world in which Supply chains spread
across borders and as that happens the
world is going to become more secure
because if you are looking to invade
your neighbor you are really going to be
cutting off your nose to spike your face
because you're going to be damaging your
neighbor's economy by so doing and
you're going to damage your own economy
by extension so this is a set of ideas
which prove to be extraordinarily
powerful as always they are more
complicated in the implementation than
they sound in the abstract but they
really do have important consequences in
changing the world and then moving the
United States to think about a different
set of goals to be achieved with a
different set of tools and in particular
the tools of the market
so that's your potted history
where are we now
well if we were in a world during the
Cold War where people thought that the
government knows best and we moved from
a world from that world into a world
where the mark knows best we're now in a
world where uh famously William Goldman
said of Hollywood that nobody knows
anything that is to say that we're in a
world where we have begun to realize
that the uh many of the promises that
were made about globalization didn't
actually turn out to be true some did it
did produce enormous prosperity in in
parts of the world which is incredibly
important but it has left a Welter of
problems and of extremely complex
problems in its wake so if you look at
the way that the Biden Administration is
thinking about the world it is very very
clear that it has taken this set of
problems quite seriously if you look at
for example speeches made by uh
officials such as the National Security
adviser Jake Sullivan or Catherine Tai
who is the U.S trade representative
argina raimondo who is the Secretary of
Commerce all of these they are singing
from the same hymn book under the hymn
book which says globalization achieved
many benefits in terms of providing
prosperity to the World Trade is good
and wonderful and so on but what we have
is a world in which this has led to many
unexpected problems proliferating and
becoming worse so they for example they
point to the ways in which the supply
chains that have spread across across
the world turn out to be incredibly
vulnerable they turn out to be fragile
when you see something like coronavirus
happening they also turn out to be
possibly usable by America's enemies
against it as well as although they
don't stress us as much for obvious
reasons by America against its own
adversaries we also see uh ways in which
climate change and sort of it's harder
to tackle because of the way that the
global economy works and we see a very
importantly the uh ways in which the uh
exchanges have really perhaps even
endangered U.S democracy if you look at
the hollowing out of U.S industry in key
parts of the Midwest this is plausibly
part of the important story for why so
many voters became dissatisfied with the
existing system and decided to place
their bets on somebody like Donald Trump
and that is a story that we are all
living with today so the Biden
Administration is looking decisively to
break with the old wisdom of
globalization with these simplifications
that I have described to its credit it
is trying to avoid not always succeeding
but doing its best try to avoid moving
back to the previous simplifications of
the Cold War which are equally
pernicious in their own ways and it is
trying to muddle through it is trying to
figure out what are the new
possibilities that you might have to
solve these incredibly incredibly
worrying problems that we face that seem
to uh perhaps endanger us all
so now I'm going to deliver on the first
part of my promise which is talking
about the polycrisis so if you look at
this if you want to look at the problem
side of the equation uh there is a lot
of value to a view that the historian
atom 2s has developed building upon an
older concept called the polycrisis to
really describe why it is that we seem
to be in such Dire Straits right now his
idea is fairly straightforward there are
many many problems out there we do not
face just one crisis we Face multiple
crises at once we Face climate change we
Face pandemic we Face War we Face some
sort of the weaponization of the economy
we Face uh vast changes in migration and
all of these problems are to some
greater or lesser extent apparently
feeding on themselves even worse they're
all feeding upon each other in some
quite important ways so just to take an
example if you think about the way the
climate change works it is plausibly
weakening democracy in certain countries
in Western Europe and we're likely to
see more and more of that happening
because as people begin to try to
respond to climate change they realize
that it's going to be incredibly costly
to make the transition to a post-carbon
economy an immediately bitter disputes
and fights begin over who is going to
pay that cost should we pay that cost at
all or should we just observe put it off
again or hope that other people other
countries will pay it instead of us and
you again begin to see this as being
something that strengthens populists
straightens the far right people who are
pushing back against democracy pushing
back against established ways of doing
things because they see this as being a
threat to their way of life similarly
you can see how climate change increases
the likelihood of migration people
fleeing parts of the world that are
becoming rapidly uninhabitable that
again poses increased political stresses
and strains as some people want to try
and welcome these people in other people
fight back against that and so Tuesday's
point is that these crises tend to
magnify and exacerbate each other that
the economic aspects and the
non-economic aspects as he puts it are
Tangled all the way down and that we
feel that we have so many different
problems competing for our attention
each of them enormous in their own right
that to some extent we lose grip on
reality we lose our understanding of
what it is that we can do because it's
very clear that no single sweeping
solution can manage to address these
multiple different problems at once so
that's one part of bad news The Bagel is
the other part so here this is an idea
that I'm taking from Ezra Klein so Ezra
is trying to diagnose the other side of
this which is that if twos is focusing
on the problems Klein is focusing on the
uh parts of policy which are intended to
address problems and he's coming up with
a diagnosis that in its own way is
equally troubling what He suggests is
that our policy process in the United
States is it's very very difficult to
get things done because of the number of
veto points that there are and because
of the tendency that policy makers have
because there are so many different
interests so many different
constituencies to try and lard on
requirement after requirement standard
after standard in order to try and you
know so to you know to use whatever
policy instruments are supposed to
achieve a single thing end up trying to
do 20 or 30 or 40 different things at
the same time
so Ezra is somebody who is a recent
transplant from California some of this
is I think a a very explicitly an
expression of his frustration with the
inability of uh people to get things
done to him sort of get planning uh
permission to observe to do big things
in California because of how many
different uh people have to sign off but
he also explicitly argues that we see
the same kind of thing happening with
the bigger geopolitical questions so
that for example he looks at the ways in
which efforts to try and get the United
States to produce semiconductors so that
it is not so reliant on the outside
world anymore and the risks the
geopolitical risks that involves that
these efforts to provide subsidies to
companies to set up semiconductor Fabs
they require child care facilities and
other things and so more or less his
argument is that the more that you try
to lard on these different kinds of
requirements the less likely it is that
your policy will be able to succeed at
any of them so in other words what we
have instead of the simplification that
we had in a different eras we have these
uh accounts of what you might call
impossible complexities from both ends
and possible complexities and the
problems that we have to deal it with
impossible complexities in the policy
processes that we have which are
supposed to deal with them and there are
important differences between the way in
which uh atom 2's and as our client
think about the world Adam tussa's
arguments suggest that we need solutions
that tackle multiple problems at once
Ezra Klein suggests that if we try to do
this we're probably likely to lose focus
but both of them I think provide reasons
for considerable pessimism about our
ability to confront the massive problems
that we need to confront
so where are we
well
I think that we're in a world where you
know the everything bagel is meeting the
poly crisis and we really need to start
thinking about what other possible ways
we might have to get forward and here
again it's not entirely wonderful uh so
you may have been able to tell from my
accent I think bits of my brogue have
probably uh broken out at one point or
another during the last uh 20-25 minutes
uh but uh I'm from Ireland and so
there's a famous joke in Ireland at
least famous to Irish people I don't
know if it's well known in the United
States it concerns an American Tourist
who finds themselves lost on the back
roads the borings as we call them of
Ireland doesn't have a clue where they
are and finally they're driving along
and they come across a farmer and they
ask the farmer how in the name of God am
I going to get to lived in Varna and the
farmer looks at them and he scratches
his chin and he thinks for a minute he
looks in this Direction he looks in that
direction he scratches his chin again
for another minute he says well if I
wanted to get there I wouldn't start
from here and I think For Better or For
Worse that is the world we are in we are
in a world where it is incredibly
difficult to see what the ways forward
are that we might have I can describe in
the abstract the kinds of policy
instruments that we would ideally like
to have we would like to have policy
instruments that were capable of first
of all identifying the complexities and
representing the complexities of the
problems that people like Adam tools
describe in ways that make them
actionable you know have theories of
well here are the weak points that we
can go after then you would like to be
able to obviously address problems to
those complexities and then these are
policies that were that address these
problems you would like to be able to
rapidly revise them it could be that
they don't work as you expect because
your model is wrong it could be that
they work much much better than you ever
expected and you want to build on them
either which way you want to be able to
do these things in the rapid and
reactive fashion and and if you read
people who write and who think about the
U.S government like Jennifer Parker you
will see that this is not the kind of
policy apparatus that we have or the
kind of policy apparatus that we are
likely to have anytime soon so I am not
going to provide you with a specific
list of guidelines as to what we do next
what I'm going to do you know so if I I
am an Irishman but I'm also an academic
which means that I have some license to
be a little bit unrealistic at times as
well I'm going to say
here are at least some very very broad
Pathways that we might want to
investigate further that are possibly
going to lead us in good directions
these are Pathways which primarily
identify ideas that have been laid out
by other people but that I think answer
provides some promise as to ways forward
that we might want to think about
first
problem-centered publics so what is the
idea here well the idea here is fairly
straightforward during the Potted
history that I've I've described we have
had an emphasis on the technocratic
state on top-down leadership we've had
an emphasis on the Miracle of markets
while we have not tried ever to do in
any very sophisticated way is to use
democracy as a means of problem solving
and problem identification
and there is an old tradition of trying
to think about that which comes from
pragmatist philosophers like John Dewey
in the early 20th century
which suggested that a democracy is as
much as anything else it's a means of
knowledge creation it's a means of
information gathering and the intuition
behind this is pretty straightforward
that uh members of the public very often
they are not particularly sophisticated
in their understanding of deep causal
mechanisms of of complex factors this
that and the other but what they do know
very well and what is often very
valuable information is how it is that
these problems actually affect them in
their day-to-day lives and so then the
question is can you bring this
information that the public has together
with people who have expertise can you
create appropriate institutions and if
you can do that you can probably also
mobilize the public in ways that give
people a genuine stake in problem
solving that they don't have at the
moment so there are people who are
thinking about this in the early 20s
21st century who are quite different
from John Dewey but who I think are
thinking in a somehow similar way
there's a wonderful science fiction
novel that I recommend that I have found
thinking and influencing my thinking
quite a lot on this by a woman called
ruthana Emirates a half-built garden
it's a little bit like if you've read
Ursula Le guins that is possessed it's a
little bit like that with high
technology what she's trying to do is
she's trying to imagine a world which is
post-climate change where you see a
technocratic government continuing you
also see uh the um sort of liberal
libertarian market-based institutions
but more than either of these things you
see people organizing around River
watersheds in a post-climate change
ecologically uh challenged World river
river watersheds are where a lot of the
action where a lot of the problems you
want to focus on are actually happening
and she gives a vision of a world in
which you can use high powered sensors
you can use some sort of discussion
debate argument fighting AIS in order to
actually get things done and it is uh
you know this is a science fictional
Vision but it actually has some very
very interesting ideas about how you
might actually begin to apply these
things in the real world and not only
that but there are some fantastic uh
younger people who are trying to think
in very similar ways and hear the people
here uh pictured are Divya siddhars and
saffron Huang who have this uh
collective intelligence project which is
really trying to figure out how can we
put Democratic institutions uh together
that better take advantage of technology
in order to solve these big broader
problems this is a strain of thinking
that really has not sort of been applied
to policy problems in the way that it
ought and that possibly offers some
solutions and also possibly offers some
improvements in democracy which as we
know is one of the major challenges that
faces us today
another possible source of insight
cybernetics so this is uh I would
imagine this is a kind of a long now
kind of topic so many of you are already
broadly familiar with the rough idea a
lot of people thinking about cybernetics
are from the 1940s on a brief Vogue in
the 1960s 1970s and then it falls out of
discussion until the very recent past
now I think that on the left we're
seeing a kind of a romanticization of
cybernetics which might not be entirely
ideal but nonetheless I think there are
some very very valuable ideas in
cybernetics if you cut through some of
the jargon which could be revived which
I think could help us especially as we
think about how to try to redesign
bureaucracy so and this is an inside I
owe to Daniel Davies who has a great
book that is coming out on this next
year people like Stafford beer tried to
figure out how to rebuild organizations
in ways that made them more responsive
to complexity and the two key lessons
that I think that they have there is
first of all you need to have ways to
actively represent the complexity of the
problem within the system that is trying
to uh resolve it and secondly that you
need to be able to design feedback loops
so that you are capable of adapting
rapidly to uh whatever Solutions are
needed and figuring out on the Fly what
works well and what works not so well
and so on and so these kinds of design
principles are not the design principles
that people think about when for example
they are designing a federal government
agencies they're not the kinds of design
principles that people think about when
they are designing uh businesses or
nonprofits there is a lot of work that
we could probably do to try and develop
this
final idea shock us hurting okay so this
is perhaps you know even weirder than
the bagel and the polycrisis if that is
possible but at the fundamental idea
here this is uh something that cosmash
litzi and I wrote for The Economist a
few months ago I vigorously disagree
with people about large language models
and other forms of Applied machine
learning are Ai and our intuition is
something like as follows there are a
lot of people who think about large
language models as being some form of
artificial general intelligence in the
making you you read Sam Altman you read
all of the people who talk about this
and there's this kind of frenzied
excitement about that many of these
people talk about large language models
there are people who worry about AI risk
they talk about them as being Shoguns
these are these are these shapeless
monstrosities from HP Lovecraft which
were created by these other shapeless
monstrosities and eventually rebel
against them and drive them into the
oceans and all sorts of unpleasant
things and so the notion that it's
supposed to be communicated is that
large language models they appear to be
human but behind their human masks are
these bubbling monstrosities of
protoplasm which are going to devour and
destroy us if they ever get half a
chance so what Cosmo and I argue is well
you can think about large language
models and similar things as being
Shockers in this sense but if they're
chocolates they're not chocolates
because they're going to become
self-aware or intelligent there's
chocolates because they are uh they are
monstrosities in the same way that
bureaucracies and markets and even
democracy can be monstrosities that is
that they are these complex systems for
taking vast and Incredibly irreducibly
complex bodies of human information and
creating useful but lossy
representations of them that is what
markets do according to Hayek prices are
in effect they are losing
representations of this much larger real
quality of incredibly complex supply and
demand decisions and that is what
bureaucracy is about according to uh
James Scott who deplores it uh
bureaucracies again they take this Rich
local knowledge and they turn it into a
thin slurry of abstract Concepts that
are actionable and so what we want to
argue is that large language models and
other forms of machine learning their
use is going to be in taking bodies of
information that democracy has you know
that that that is possessed in the by
the body of democratic citizens are
alternatively that is a possessed within
bureaucracies and making it more useful
making it more uh more readily available
by generating lossy but still
nonetheless useful summaries of the
information which provides possibly a
new set of ways of handling complexity
and perhaps
enables some of the uses of cybernetics
some of the uses of democratic public
that we talked about earlier but
providing technologies that actually
allow them to work at scale potentially
in ways that they have not in the past
so that's where we are and I don't think
that these are particularly satisfactory
action answers they really are less
answers than waving in the direction of
methodologies which may produce answers
one day and that means that we can't
rely on this on its own I think that we
do need to start thinking about and
focusing on immediate problems that we
can solve with the tools that we have to
hand but at the same time and again this
is a very long now way of thinking about
it I think we need to think towards the
future and we also need to think as we
are solving smaller problems we start
small but we want to think about what
are the destinations that we have in
mind what are the bigger tools that we
can build and how can we try to scale
these tools up over time so that they
solve the bigger more profound problems
that really challenge us that really
could in the end of the day destroy us
if we don't do something about them so
that's where I want to finish I want to
also thank many people and sort of the
if you have heard anything that sounds
to you even halfway intelligence during
this conversation this is due to uh one
of the many co-authors that I uh show
you in the slide are else alternatively
it is due to one of the many people who
I have collaborated with on other stuff
in the past or who have just given me
advice or whatever if there is anything
that is deeply and interimated
remediately stupid it is all down to me
so thank you all very much and with that
I guess I will finish the talk and look
forward to the further conversation
thank you
[Applause]
what a great talk Henry
um I want to start by with a quote from
Karl Marx that many of you are probably
familiar with Marx famously said that
men make history but they do not make it
just as they please they make they do
not make it under circumstances chosen
by themselves but under circumstances
directly encountered given transmitted
from the past
um and one thing I struck by in your
talk and also in the book and I do want
to plug all the things he said about the
book are absolutely true that it's
fantastic book go get it one of the
things that really comes out in your
talk and in your book is the question of
past dependence like the the the the way
in which the era of the technocratic
state the cold war that emerges out of
you know World War II and the Great
Depression era before it the era of
globalization and Market centricity
emerges out of some of the failings of
the previous system and we're now living
in the failures of globalization and
some new system is emerging that we
don't yet have a name for
so I'm wondering when you think about
that the way in which new systems new
macro systems emerge out of the
contradictions that engulfed the
previous system what are the limits to
the Futures that we have available to us
long term that the polycrisis that
globalization has bequeathed us are
imposing what are the possibility spaces
that are not available to us anymore so
that's a very good question and there
are a lot of spaces that are not
available to us which might have been
available 30 or 40 years ago and I think
about this not just in terms of path
dependence which is really how our past
institutional habits reinforce our
future ones but also just in terms of
resources that are unavailable to us are
changes to the physical environment
which are things that social scientists
Like Me by and large don't pay attention
to we treat them as being constants and
of course they're variables and they're
variables which in many ways are going
in the wrong direction right now so I
think Joseph we you know if we had had
the intelligence to begin to tackle some
of these problems 30 to 40 years ago I
think we to be in a different world
equally and this gets to the topics of
the book more than it gets to the topics
of the talk that I've just given if
people had realized how much
geopolitical risk was going to be
involved in globalization 30 or 40 years
ago it really would never have happened
so I think one of the things that I
thought about when I was writing this
book is so we describe how it is that
the people who tried to build the
globalized world and there's this
wonderfully interesting character called
Walter Reston he is a genuinely good
intellectual he is Thomas Friedman
without the stupid but in addition to
being a sorry that was probably a bit
mean I've got a whole Riff on Thomas
Friedman I could give you which is even
meaner if you wanted to ask me for it
later but uh but but wrist and in
addition to being an intellectual he's
also the CEO of Citibank he's the person
who actually makes many of the changes
that we see and so he then he believes
that he is building a world which is
fundamentally going to be decentralized
and out of the power of the state and
other people think that this is what is
happening too and if people had realized
at the time then I think that we would
never have seen globalization going
nearly so far because countries such as
China and indeed the United States would
have been too worried about the
long-term security consequences and one
of the turning points of History I think
is there's we described this economist a
political Economist Erica leiner who is
uh a just a brilliant person and also an
extraordinarily decent human being so
halliner back when riston is saying
these things he quietly and politely
points out well you're saying that
you're creating a world that cannot be
controlled by governments but this is
going through all of these Financial
flows that you are creating are going
through choke points in London and New
York and the United States or other
powers could take control and I think if
people have paid attention to what Erica
liner was saying 30 or 40 years ago I
think globalization would have been uh
would have been a bust I don't think we
would I don't think it would have been a
complete bust but I think we would have
seen much less trade and much less
willingness to rely upon common systems
than we have now and this is something
that I think turns to I things that you
think about and worry about which is we
are now in a world where we need to
create more common systems to uh fight
climate change to figure out the
transition to a post-carbon economy and
we're doing so in a situation of
profound distrust which is a result of
globalization having gone sour so I
think one of the big challenges we have
is uh you know given that we are in
these historical conditions which as
Mark said are not of our making what
possibilities for agency do we have and
this is part of what we try to do in the
book is to say first of all try to get
out of the Spiral that you are in with
China where uh this mutual hostility and
suspicion is building is built you know
so China's suspicion is building on on
the United States states in the United
States is building on China and secondly
start to think about while you have this
power what kinds of collective Endeavors
can you apply this to which could
legitimate it and which could also
perhaps help to solve some of these
problems as well great great uh I I want
to put a pin in the question of what
should we do for a second and State uh
instead for a moment about trying to
imagine what are the Futures we're
likely to get so what is the
post-globalization future going to look
like there's been a couple of uh books
that have been published recently on
this that I think might be relevant for
thinking about this the political
scientist Steve Weber wrote a book A
couple of years ago called block by
block where he anticipated that we're
basically going to break away from a
single Global integrated Market into a
series of regionally defined blocks one
is centered on East Asia maybe one
Center on North America dominated by the
United States maybe one centered on
Europe and that we'll see much less
trade between these what's interesting
about that as a kind of a prediction of
the future of where we're going or a
forecast of the Futures you know people
are talking about how terrible
realization is but you know you actually
aren't seeing that much decline in
global trade yet you're seeing changes
in the global structure but the actual
numbers have not declined likewise on a
little more technical basis the
philosophy the philosopher of Technology
Benjamin Bratton wrote a book a few
years ago called the stack where he
talked about how these different blocks
in in Weber's terms are actually defined
by fundamentally different Hardware
layers software layers regulatory layers
so you're going to end up with pretty
much different stacks of technology
which will allow for the separation of
these different systems but are we
actually going to see that can we
actually I mean this is the path
dependency Point can we actually get to
a point where we break back to a cold
war world where we really have separated
walls I really don't think so I think uh
What uh Steve Weber's book so I still
haven't read Bratz book uh it's a spice
the spice having had it on my bookshelf
for two years with it's pretty fast yeah
yeah it's pretty fast so uh but but I I
think when I read Steve's book I think
about Kane's quote about how uh people
your politicians who fancy that they're
completely free for from ideas are
caught up in the frenzy of some
Scribbler uh right and uh Steve Webber
is one of those scribblers because if he
predicted what the conventional wisdom
was going to be which is the
conventional wisdom right now is that we
are going to break up into blocks I
think that there is probably more
evidence uh than in the public debate
that there is there are changes in trade
patterns happening equally I don't think
we're ever going to get into a world
that resembles the Cold War World I
think that the United States economy and
the Chinese economy are too deeply and
Reliant upon each other for that to
happen and if you look at what the uh
what Sullivan and uh Raymondo when she
went to China a couple of weeks ago are
doing they are really pushing for what
they call a uh a small yard high fence
model which is one in which the in which
restrictions would be applied only to a
relatively narrow set of technologies
that have obviously dire strategic or
military implications it's going to be
really hard to maintain that because the
problem is that the yard is going to
keep on getting bigger and bigger and
bigger I think that if you look at the
policy debate in DC there is a huge
amount of fear of China but I also think
that the two have too much at stake in
each other's uh each other's
interconnections for there to ever be a
really really decisive break so I think
instead we're going to get something
which is
you know if it's like the cold war it's
in the weird ambiguities of the Cold War
more than in the uh sense of rigid
separations of systems it's going to be
like a kind of a John le Carrie Cold War
where all of the interesting stuff is
happening in the messy interstices and
where people are trying to manage these
interstices in order to make sure that
our really bad bad stuff doesn't happen
Okay so this gets us to the question
what do we what do we do about this
um one of the things you talk about a
little bit in the talk and also in the
book is that you know what's happened is
because of these choke points you're
describing that go through London or go
through New York or go through Northern
Virginia choke points that are Financial
infrastructure that are informational
infrastructure the U.S and the argument
you make in the book is that the turning
point is really 9 11 and the global war
on terror where initially we realized we
could chase down terrorists and and
Chase down terrorist Finance by
monitoring these systems that we have
basically you know I can put our
eyeballs on and you have this anecdote
that you tell all about something that
happened right here in San Francisco
where like you know was it a t that they
put in they put in a splicer so that
they could actually read all the data
that's coming in from from Asia right so
all of this became possible and was
initially done during the Panic moments
after 9 11 and then it sort of got
institutionalized but then the US
realized well we don't just have to do
we we don't have to restrict ourselves
just to doing this for terrorists we can
do this for other kinds of Bad actors
that we want to put pressure on the
Iranians well maybe we consider them
terrorists too but now the Chinese also
so you have a whole narrative that you
tell about how this sort of emerged
organically out of sort of initially the
panicked moments of nine Post 9 11 and
then got institutionalized during the
global war on terror and you basically
think your argument I think is that this
is a mistake because it's going to drive
more paranoia and it's going to drive
separation and we're going to lose the
benefits of globalization with very few
upsides in exchange and you argue
instead that we should be thinking more
about these this infrastructure as a
commonwealth as a common shared resource
talk to me a little bit about how that
would look differently from what the US
the posture the U.S has been taking over
last 20 years so it's
so this is one of the areas I think that
the final chapters of books are there's
a reason why they are unsatisfying uh
usually which is it is really hard to
come up with a convincing and compelling
solutions to problems so I think what we
offer in the Final Chapter I don't think
that we're ever going to be able to get
into a full Commonwealth situation I
think that there is just too much
hostility and distrust and equally and
this is the uh side that is impressed
upon me by U.S officials who are grumpy
with the book and I think it is a very
reasonable point because when they look
at China China is an authoritarian
regime which does terrible things to
uyghurs which is not a particularly nice
neighbor to have and there are very good
reasons why the United States wants to
press back against China as much as
possible and why other countries if they
were thinking straight about this at
least other democracies would uh view
this as being a very often a pretty good
thing so so but we're never going to be
able to get away from uh Power we're
never going to be able to get away from
the the fundamental fact that we live in
a world where uh where there aren't
International restraints on power of
that sort so what we are looking for
from the United States is less that they
give up the keys to Empire than that
they try not to exercise it in Stupid
Ways and they try to exercise it for the
common benefit so if there is a ghost
hanging over that a segment of the
argument I think that it is the ghost of
uh another famous economist Charles
kindleberger who made these Arguments
for uh hegemony back in the 1970s and
more or less what he said is the United
States is a global hegemon that is it is
in charge of the global economy but you
need a hedge a month sometimes to knock
heads together when there is a crisis
and to make sure that everybody
coordinates to do the right thing if you
have the United States moving towards a
model of hegemony I think that will be a
better situation than the situation
we're in equally if I want to think
about the good arguments against what we
say I think a lot of the good arguments
would be that we are writing really from
the perspective of the powerful
governments the powerful states in the
system and if you are somebody who is at
the receiving end of some of these
things even if it seems to you plausibly
that uh perhaps this is sometimes going
to be in the common good it is also
going to be the common good as defined
by the United States and there's also
going to be a lot of selfishness in that
definition International politics being
what international politics are so I can
imagine that we very plausibly and very
reasonably are going to get a lot of
grief and pushback from people for
saying you know for not being more
critical of the Empire than we are so on
the one hand as I say there are people
who I think are reasonably grumpy at us
some sort of from within the Biden
Administration and Elsewhere on the
other there are people who are
reasonably unhappy who think that we
give the U.S much too easier at time in
our argument and you know I think both
of those are reasonable points of
criticism when you write a book like
this you're obviously making a strong
argument but you're not making an
argument thinking that it is the only
appropriate argument out there you also
recognize that there are other
perspectives other points of view which
uh very reasonably are going to come to
quite different understandings of the
world than you do
um I think one of the things that's
interesting about about the position you
find yourself in now Henry is that you
know if you look at every decade
there's always a couple of key Concepts
that come become you can say maybe the
cliche of the Arab the defining kind of
features so we always people often say
that the 1990s were defined by the end
of History right or the debate between
Frank fukuyama arguing that we're at the
end of history on the one hand and Sam
Huntington claiming no no no we're
facing the Clash of civilizations on the
other and that that was sort of a key
debate in the 1990s
um Tom Friedman's argument about the
world being flat as a kind of defining
defining cliche of the era of
globalization in the early odds in the
1990s too
um your argument that you made in the
book actually started as an article that
was entitled weaponized interdependence
and that term I think could be one of
those key Concepts from the 2020s that
in in decades in the future people will
look back and say oh that was a really
key concept for understanding the era
and the reason why I say that is that
although you started you wrote this
article with Abraham as a mode of
analysis it's now been picked up
by the policy makers themselves to
describe what they're doing you help
them understand
what they themselves were engaged in and
gave them a vocabulary for understanding
and even though you guys were kind of
critical and you're being critical now
of this people have picked it up and
said yeah that's what I want to do
weaponized interdependence
and I bring this up because this brings
a really interesting issue from a long
now perspective which is when you make
scenarios about the future
one of the things I always think about
when I do that kind of work is am I
actually making that future more or less
likely when I start to describe that
future and if it's a negative future you
want to describe it in a way
that makes it less likely to happen
rather than more likely to happen and
I'm wondering if you've had any sort of
misgivings about the way in which this
concept has been picked up even though
you meant it critically by people who
are now saying oh my God that's what I
want to do and you're actually creating
the future that you were trying to ward
off so this is something that we think
about and that we worry about I think
about it so William Gibson has a famous
dictum the street Finds Its Own uses for
things I think what we have discovered
is the elite Finds Its Own uses for
things too and uh so one of the stories
we tell in the book I think about this
uh you may be familiar with there's a
famous internet meme about the torment
Nexus this is a Twitter meme back when
Twitter was actually a service you
wanted to use where you have uh more or
less somebody describing uh you know
science fiction writer writes this novel
called Don't create the torment Nexus
and then a Silicon Valley company
announces we have created the torment
Nexus described in uh science fiction
writers don't create the torment and
access how awesome we are and so I kind
of feel a little bit like that with some
of the uses that are being made of the
terms so one of the things that was
actually quite terrifying for us was uh
Chris Miller who wrote this book called
Chip War which is a very very good book
on semiconductors which I didn't I
bought the day that it came out
terrified that I would discover that
what we were arguing about
semiconductors was completely wrong
happily that didn't turn out to be the
case but then I got about three quarters
of the way into the book and I discover
Henry Farrell and Abraham's Newman's
name coming up and so Chris who is uh
somewhat more on the conservative side
of the spectrum than we are talks to an
anonymous high-level Trump official who
says more or less we read the weaponized
interdependence article or I read the
interdependence this article I thought
that this was a in Chris's description a
wonderful quote game plan unquote and
then I'm sort of we went and we
implemented it in in the Chinese in the
restrictions against uh Chinese company
huawei's uh access to semiconductors
which has of course given birth to uh
Biden's uh Biden's plan and Biden's
efforts to restrict China's uh access as
a whole to the semiconductors that are
used to power AI so in other words
because we found ourselves in sort of
having warned as Chris says in this book
we find ourselves having you know we
warned you that this is something that
can be overused we don't want to see the
world becoming this world and in fact it
was used by Trump Administration
officials to do this so I I I I guess
the constellation for this is is that I
suspect that something like this policy
would probably have emerged in any event
it would have been given a slightly
different name being justified in
slightly different ways but it's also
possible it might not have been one of
the real lessons that I think we learned
when we were writing this book is so
much depends on happenstance so much
depends on one official having a
particular idea at a particular time and
then this stuff gets set in stone and
there's another part of this which is
there's a part of the book you know
where I describe briston's ideas and I
say something like yes if I say
something together with Abe something
like uh When people's ideas succeed they
turn into they degenerate into stale
cliches that you get in business
bestsellers and more or lessons ideas
become use of what you see piled up in
fat heaps during the 1990s and 2000s in
airport bookstores around the world and
so I also have a kind of feeling if if
we succeed we are only going to succeed
in the sense that people will take up
these ideas and perhaps they will use
these ideas but then there are going to
be other things that I and Abe never
anticipated that are going to turn these
ideas into the stale cliches that a new
generation of people are going to rip
down so that is the academic life cycle
and I think as I get older I think one
of the great virtues that older
academics like me serve is we we're
excellent scratching posts for younger
academics to sharpen their clothes on
and to figure out how to uh how to get
better uh you know use this target
practice and if they're only sharpening
their clothes and not using us for
others or possible functions I think
we're doing extremely well out of the
experience okay
um I want to take some questions from
the audience Philip asks um many of the
problems you're describing are worsened
by overpopulation now scientists say our
populations will soon start declining
what impact will population decline have
but I want to broaden this because
in the middle of the poly crisis we have
as globalization loses legitimacy and a
new world is emerging there's a number
of really deep long-term trends I mean
you mentioned climate change obviously
the carbon that we put in the atmosphere
is not going away for hundreds of years
that's you know money in the bank for
better or worse likewise it seems pretty
clear that we're going to see
demographic decline towards the end of
the century and we're going to see
massive demographic shifts population
will start to decline in uh in Europe
probably in Northeast Asia pretty pretty
rapidly but it's going to continue to
grow in places like South Asia and in
Africa we can also talk about other
kinds of long-term deep Trends how are
those things going to affect the world
that emerges out of the poly crisis that
we have now do you think it's a really
good question that I don't have
particularly good answers to I think
it's incredibly important as I said at
the beginning social scientists like at
least standard social scientists don't
pay nearly enough attention to these
changes in the physical environment and
also in the demographic environment
I do think this is probably going to
have consequences for the U.S China
relationship because uh one of uh and
you could so here's one way of thinking
about it you could see it in positive or
negative ways if you're looking at this
from the point of view of the United
States the United States faces
demographic decline it does not face
anything like the demographic Cliff that
China is facing into and that could have
real consequences for China's ability to
maintain its power over the longer term
so perhaps if you are a U.S uh
politician thinking about this you're
cheering at the likelihood that this
Challenger is going to fall away but
equally you could make the case and this
is a case that's made by one of my size
colleagues Hal brands that this means
that it is precisely at the moment of
the peak that you're likely to see um
sort of the push on the basis that if we
don't do it now we're never going to be
able to do it so I think so that is a
very uh indirect way of saying I think
that these are incredibly important
figuring out what kinds of consequences
they will have for the kinds of past
dependent policy political paths that
are Abe and I describe is really really
hard to do because they're in a sense
they're different levels of argument you
know so you know the the you can think
about the demographic thing as being
like the environment because this is a
set of strictures which restrict the
kinds of things that we can or cannot do
in the future equally this is going to
result in a series of unexpected shocks
to the existing system and how those
sharks that play out are going to depend
upon all sorts of incredibly complicated
and difficult to predict uh factors out
of your temporary factors that may come
into play at a particular moment in time
so uh so that is a very sort of
highfaluting way of saying uh I think
it's really important which particular
ways it's going to be important I'm
probably not the right person to ask
all right I want to pick up on another
question this is from Joseph he says do
we have the possibility of doing Mass
collaboration like Wikipedia to address
these large problems I think you were
touching on that a little bit in
reference to Divya and saffron's work
and thinking about the way in which we
can use technology and large language
models to do you know attach to try to
solve some of these problems I mean we
tend to see the the majority of the
discourse right now around
the impact of technology on our
democracies is that it's a bad it's you
know undermining you know we're going to
get massive amounts of deep fakes and
we're going to have massive amounts of
specially targeted disinformation and so
on but what are the possibilities the
upside possibilities that these new
technology Suites are creating including
large language models but also new
collaboration tools for addressing some
of these challenges go a little more in
detail about that okay that's a great
question and I could talk for hours
about it and this also makes me feel
embarrassed because there's a whole
bunch of other collaborators who are not
on sort of in that last thing uh in
particular Melissa schwartzberg and Hugo
Mercier who are just wonderful academics
and we have a set of arguments around us
and here's and Wikipedia actually
features into this story in some
interesting ways so Hugo Mercier I would
really recommend that everybody buy his
and dance berber's book the Enigma of
reason I think this is a stone cold
classic of the social sciences it is uh
and their argument is really good really
interesting they're cognitive
psychologists and they argue with
follows first of all human reasoning did
not evolve as a way of figuring out the
world it evolved as a means for us
providing plausible sounding
justifications for what it is that we
want to get in a social situation so we
you know we reason in order to come up
with good excuses for why what we want
is what everybody should want too so
that means that is a standard argument
it is a a source of cognitive bias it
means that we we but we are not
capable ourselves of detecting or
smelling our own okay so that's
part one of the argument the second part
of the argument is where it gets really
interesting which is that we are
terrible at detecting our own
but because this is so important yes
because we are a social uh species we
are by and large we're pretty good at
detecting others and so then
this means that you can harness people's
cognitive bias against each other so you
and I disagree strenuously on observe I
don't know who who has to pay for dinner
I've got great arguments on my side
you've got great arguments on your side
but are but probably at the beginning we
don't have great arguments I've got
terrible arguments and you round
immediately on the floor in my argument
and I round on the floor and your
argument and it ends up perhaps we uh
converge to some degree but at the very
least we end up with better arguments so
the fundamental notion here is that
individual level cognitive flaws can
result in better group level reasoning
if we are prepared to engage with other
people who we disagree with and so this
then has interesting consequences for
Wikipedia because what this is it
suggests that you can use people's
Tendencies to be as the fuel
for actual good yo not collaboration but
for actually I'm sort of figuring stuff
out and this is in part the story of
Wikipedia there is a work that has been
done by a Chicago sociologist James
Evans he uses he and his colleagues use
national natural language processing to
look at Wikipedia and to look at the
amount of disagreement there is on
Wikipedia pages and the fundamental
finding that they find is that the
greater the degree of polarization and
tension that there is in a given
Wikipedia talk page the better the
quality of the resulting argument so
this is not because people end up loving
each other and seeing Kumbaya they still
hate each other at the end of the day
but they grudgingly recognize that there
are good arguments it's kind of like
that onion article of the person you
know the worst person I know just made a
great argument this is the logic that we
can actually harness to make Democratic
institutions work better and Wikipedia
because it is able to harness the
someone on the Internet is wrong thing
and make that into a force of
intellectual Discovery it's a very very
interesting model for us to do it that's
great this is a question from Ariel
she says the the climate transition
today is playing a similar role to
globalization 40 years ago everybody has
to transition the same way everybody had
to globalize what are we missing what
would be the equivalent insight to
Helena's prescient argument about the
dangers of globalization with respect to
climate oh my God that is a fascinating
question so
okay
I'm trying to think this through I mean
and I think in some ways you would
actually be a better person to ask the
answer this question okay this is a
really mean trick to play but but uh you
know so what I'm thinking here is you
know so we we gesture in the end of the
book towards talking about climate
change as a being one place where these
kinds of structures could actually work
well uh and you know the idea is that
you do need somebody to uh to kit to
knock people's heads together sometimes
people know that this is a problem but
they don't necessarily have the
wherewithal to uh to do it domestically
and if there's somebody who is forcing
everybody to uh get on the same page
then this can work out uh really well so
and here we are in some senses we're
responding to uh Kim Sally Robinson Stan
Robinson who's another wonderful person
who helped greatly to form the ideas of
the book you know the ministry of the
future it has similar other ideas about
central banks we're not sure that
central banks could do it but it could
be that this form of uh benign
imperialism could do it so I could see
it either way you could make an argument
that uh the people who are resisting and
pressing back against this benign
imperialism don't realize that over the
longer term it is they're in their
interest to have somebody who pushes
them around as long as this Pro this uh
this power does things that don't sort
of help towards the answer of global
interest equally you could see ways in
which uh the uh willingness of the
United States to get high on its own
Supply which is something that I think
is a characteristic constant of U.S and
so you you do not get anywhere in U.S
politics by uh thinking that the U.S
ever does bad things in the world I
could see this I'm sort of leading the
United States to uh overestimate its
degree of support in the world and I
think you could make an argument that is
part part of the story of Ukraine it's
very clear that the United States
assumed that when is swung in behind
Ukraine in the fight against Russia that
it was going to get a ton of support
from countries around the world not from
China probably but from places like
South Africa and the degree of hostility
that the United States has gotten has
shocked and horrified senior U.S
officials and caused some major
rethinking and also I think this is
something that if this had happened if
this had been clear when we have been
finishing writing the book we would
probably have have had some slightly
different arguments to take account of
that so those are two diametrically
opposed kind of Erica leiner points but
maybe that is somewhere at least begin
to answer that question you mentioned uh
Kim Stanley Robinson who's given a long
now talk on on this topic one of the
things I've talked to Stan about a
number of times is that
one of the reasons it's important to
have you know visions of the future
plans of the future even if they're
totally out there ideas that don't seem
possible within the current construct is
that they can suddenly become possible
and he imagines in the opening chapters
of Ministry of the future a horrible
heat wave in India that kills 10 million
people in a couple of weeks man and this
is such a shock to the system that all
of a sudden possibilities for
institutional reform which currently
seem impossible become possible because
people are willing to consider things
because the crisis has gotten so acutely
bad
um so there's a question here from
Alessia Hendricks which I think is
direct directly on this you know can a
crisis be averted within a short period
of time and can you imagine a scenario
in which to go back to the question of
my own was just asking the climate would
be the thing that would
flip us into a new system that was about
much more International collaboration or
does that just seem impossible given as
an international relations scholar you
believe in the Anarchy of the
International System is impossible to
overcome there's always going to be
National rivalries that Trump everything
or is it possible in your mind the
division of the future could be realized
in a moment of Crisis I think everything
is possible and I think that the
fundamental defect and flaws of the
social sciences is that we uh yo we are
we are stuck with the predictions about
the systems and the assumptions that we
make and we do not pay nearly enough
attention to contingency to
possibilities and you know I think also
of another great science fiction writer
Ursula Le Guin and the argument that she
may you know she makes about on sort of
well capitalism uh seems like it'll
stick around forever people thought that
the right of of Kings was going to stick
around forever a couple of centuries ago
and look what has happened to that so I
think that there is always there is you
know you can be a pessimist as a social
scientist and I think social scientists
tend to be pessimists because in a sense
are the ways in which we think about the
world limit the possibility of agency we
think about the world in terms of big
structures and how these structures uh
of politics limit the ability of people
to get things done and we don't
recognize the moments of contingency
when stuff can actually happen so I
think that we are the kinds of wisdom
that we offer is it is useful it is
valuable because most of the time we are
stuck in a world in which the realities
are as they are and we have to try to uh
we have to try and accommodate ourselves
to that and we have to try and work
within the systems that we have but
there are these openings up and so I
would have a slightly different version
of Stan's notion of the value of a book
like the ministry for the future so if
you look at how Adam describes the
polycrisis atom 2 describes the
polycrisis you know he does say that one
of the features of polycrisis is that it
is a paralyzing in this intellect it is
intellectually paralyzing and so I think
the fact that Stan wrote that book uh
even if the solutions very often weren't
the plausible solutions that uh you know
we're going to reach some of them are
really interesting others like his
discussion of cryptocurrency uh he has
probably I think the site himself was
not a particularly good idea the fact
that you are beginning to argue about
that and inviting counter argument
creates a space case for exploration of
possibilities and this is one of the
things that I think that good science
fiction of that sort has always been
important in doing in generating the
sense that there and this gets back to
your first question that there are
possible Futures beyond the Futures that
seem to us to be uh inevitably as they
are and uh and so to the extent that we
can balance the uh you know this is gram
shiam sort of has this famous line of
course about the uh pessimism of the
intellect the optimism of the will so
you want to combine the pessimism of the
social scientist with the optimism of
the science fiction writer in order to
get a uh better sense of yes it is
really hard yes 99 of the time it is a
miserable grind you do not know what the
better future is that you're working
towards but there may be these sudden
flares of possibility where things
temporarily open up and new and crazy
and wonderful possibilities May emerge
see I one thing I disagree with um
with uh Adam twos about concerning the
poly crisis I don't think I think it's
people feel paralyzed particularly in
policy making roles right now in some
places but I actually think we're at a
moment it's a sort of exciting time to
be at the long now I think there's a
tremendous amount of openness and
possible new futures
um that people are imagining and the
possibility space is wide open and there
are these moments where there's an
interregnum between different systems if
you look back at the poly crisis of the
1970s for example there were a lot of
Futures including some created by Stuart
brand who founded along now you know
that people thought everybody was going
to go live in communes and go back to
the land right that was a possibility
space that was explored by millions of
people right ended up not being the
future we got we instead we got you know
Reagan's morning in America but like
there was possibility spaces that were
wide open for a particular point in time
that then get taken over and go into a
specific Direction you know I think you
were just quoting there's another
famousgram she quote about you know
we're living in a Time Crisis and the
old dying this new is struggling to be
born yeah and this is the time of
monsters right but I do think that the
monster space and you brought up a
monster at the end of your talk is also
a space of opportunity because we could
create a new world by fighting those
monsters and so I'm wondering if we can
close by sort of a vision of what is the
opportunity space so instead of worrying
about the shagaths like as a negative
thing are these things actually things
we can harness and create a positive
future for ourselves in the vision that
you have coming out of this policy
crisis okay so when cosma and I were
writing this piece you know a lot of the
time we're involved and they applied
friendly argument with some uh you know
this is how I write I write by arguing
and the person I think we were arguing
implicitly with is Ted Chang who is
another wonderful person one wonderful
science fiction writer who wrote this
really fascinating piece for the New
Yorker which said more or less that uh
large language models that they were
creating blurry jpegs and I think that
Ted is absolutely right in this but
equally I think that blurry jpegs of
huge corpuses of human knowledge are
actually pretty damn awesome things to
have and that if you look at everything
around us we live in a world which is
built on blurry jpegs market prices are
blurry jpegs they are they they are
flawed representations of this
incredibly inherently complex underlying
system of markets uh you have high
income sort of says one thing Joseph
stiglitz who's another Nobel
prize-winning Economist has really
interesting arguments about how prices
simply cannot represent all of the
information that they are supposed to
represent nonetheless we couldn't live
without them because they turn out
you're having an Economy based on prices
is incredibly useful James Scott and
sort of complains and deplores
bureaucracy but he also grudgingly
acknowledges that Modern Life will be
impossible without these abstractions uh
inadequate and miserable as they are so
I think that we are in a new possibility
space with large with models I think
that and I think that uh that there is a
kind of like the answer of joke about in
terms of how it is you know people on
the left they they they react I think
correctly to the worries that this is
going to uh be used in ways which are
going to undermine huge parts of the
economy including parts of the economy
the people on the left very often have a
stake in you know so that user symbol
manipulators we are all simple
manipulators and a lot of simple
manipulators are going to find
themselves in a much more precarious uh
life positions because of this equally I
think that there's a tendency to say
well Joseph the food is terrible and it
comes in such small portions in other
words because of that uh these these
these models I'm sort of they they
aren't going to work and and they are
going to work but they're going to work
in ways that have terrible consequences
at the same time and those two things do
not compute so I do think that the more
that the the better way of arguing
against the application of large
language models is from another article
that Ted Chang wrote where he more or
less says that machine learning as it's
being deployed reflects the power
asymmetries in society that is it is the
people who already have power who are
shaping the ways in which this is being
deployed the uses that are considered to
be acceptable the uses that are
considered to be unacceptable and I
think that as long as that is true I
think that it becomes much much more
difficult to use large language models
or to use other forms of machine
learning because other forms of machine
learning are also incredibly important
in the ways that the more optimistic and
hopeful ways that I described at the end
of the talk so in a sense you know
before the technology comes to politics
and we really need to pay attention to
the Politics as part of this story but
that said I do think that there are many
many interesting possible crazy
unexpected uses that you could make of
these technology that could have very
very interesting benefits and could as I
say make it easier to solve some of
these problems that appear to us to be
insuperable right now great I think it's
a great note to end on thank you very
much Henry Farrell thank you
thanks that was great
[Music]